so the destruction of the Nordstrom
pipeline the natural gas pipeline that
carried well natural gas from east to
west Europe was the single most profound
Act of environmental terrorism in
history it released more deadly CO2 into
the atmosphere it was also an attack on
our NATO allies our NATO allies are the
beneficiaries of the natural gas
pipeline Germany which is the core of
European NATO suffered so the by
Administration was talking about how
much it loves NATO attacked NATO and
they did it they promised to carry it
out they haven't really denied that they
did it so during interview with Donald
Trump yesterday we thought we'd ask who
does he think did it we previewed the
answer last night here's the full
Exchange
hoopla up the Nordstrom pipeline
I don't want to get our country in
trouble so I won't answer it but uh
I can tell you who it wasn't was Russia
I bet when they blamed Russia as you
know they said Russia blew up their own
pipeline you got a kick out of that one
too
it was in Russia
so I won't answer the question only
because I don't want to get our country
yeah any deeper than they already are
but it sort of all starts we have you
know we have the most incredible
equipment I rebuilt our whole military
we have things that are you can do
anything
we're equipped to do anything but I
refuse to say it because I want our
country to be pristine
but it was a
you know in many ways blowing it up was
very bad because it really
created a lot of problems for Europe in
terms of the cost of energy oh yeah but
they shouldn't have ever been I had that
pipeline stuff Nordstrom too I had it
stopped totally stopped when Biden came
in he approved it and they immediately
started the finishing action I had
noticed him because I said for Germany
and Europe to get their energy from
Russia
that was when I said I sent Angela
Merkel the the flag I said to the white
flag of surrender she said but why but
why do you do that I said you've been
fighting Russia for many years if you
ever have to fight with Russia and they
control energy you might as well just
take the white flag of surrender that's
what I did so uh
that was blown up and uh very dangerous
to do it
but I think most people know who did it
so once we start blowing up other
people's critical infrastructure is
there a concern ours can get blown up in
return well I think it's much more than
infrastructure you're talking about look
we could end up in World War III over
this whole thing forget about pipeline
we are closer I believe it's the most
dangerous period of time in history
number one because we have people on top
that are incompetent that's number one
and again China is fine if you know how
to deal rush it if you're not a deal
Russia wasn't going into Ukraine with me
China wasn't going into Taiwan with me
I mean now all you see is you know China
with ships all over the place and
sending airplanes and bombers
that wasn't happening with me he knew
you can't do it
and also Russia knew you can't do it
they would have never done it
the most dangerous period of time
because of Weaponry because of nuclear
because of Weaponry most dangerous
period of time in the history
of our country and in the history of the
world right now and we have an
incompetent person at the top
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight